klickt
jörg schön dass david beckham playmobil
luther 95 thesen nutzer wohl über alles
mutter steht durch die straßen und
häuser überall plakate es los ja ja
meine mutter jubiläum von 17 anbietern
seine 95 thesen die wir hier sehen
angeschlagen es hat uns diese chance
verpasst naja ist ja gar nicht so glaube
die tiefen überhaupt eingeschlagen hat
es gibt davon berichte aber diejenigen
die davon berichten die waren zu dieser
zeit gar nicht in wittenberg zum
beispiel am steuer hat es nicht ganz
klar aber geschrieben hatte rief als auf
lateinisch und dann wurden sie ziemlich
schnell besetzt ins deutsche und fanden
nach reisenden absatz weil es ja den
buchdruck gab der kontrast und
vermarktet auf jeden fall ein interesse
das mobil zu sein und auch
philosophisches fand genau also martin
luther ist ja eigentlich theologe wie
kommt die philosophie da was warum
interessiert unser traum ins unsere vier
oscars genau also fängt schon mit dem
namen an luthers nämlich gut wenn nicht
gar nicht gut an nicht mehr days
gezahlten hilfen lotter oder noch immer
wieder zu helfen
und er hat sich dann 1507 gesehen
am 31 als er die wahl findet man sieht
eh wieder verschickt hat erzbischof
albrecht hat er unterzeichnet mit luther
alle hat sich einen neuen namen gegeben
und luther kommt von krimis erläuterung
und die leute raus heißt frei und wer
frei
also luther hat sich praktisch lips
einen namen gegeben der philosophische
natur ist könnte der freiherr wir sind
mutig gespielt so für das thema und
damit kann man glaube ich ziemlich
erklären und das interessante ist
natürlich der freie mensch ja er hat
gerade die these vertreten dass wir uns
frei sind
in einer gewissen hinsicht zumindest hat
nämlich eine schrift verfasst die haie
bvb trio vom freien willen zum ok also
insofern recht aktuelle der philosophie
gibt es häufig immer wieder tiefen liebe
sagen wir sind eigentlich gar nicht frei
immer willensfreiheit und determinismus
genauso eine t shirt oder auch vertrieb
jetzt nicht so sehr die terminiert durch
die natur durch hohe qualität sondern
ihr durch gottes vorher wird gut
gefallen hat das ist auch eine form von
vitamin c und sagt wir sind als menschen
angesicht gottes einmal fein gemacht
nicht frei und das ist natürlich schon
damals verstand gerede geraten hat zum
beispiel den heidelberger disputation
von 518 ein zitat geschrieben gläser vor
das vermögen nach dem sündenfall ist ein
großer name und in dem es tut was und
seinen kräften steht sündigt es tödlich
hat natürlich der katholischen kirche
nicht gefallen und papst weder fiel
glatt nicht bald eine bulle erlassen
eine klageschrift wie auf 529 und ich
lese vor weise darin gesagt hat die
vorgenannten artikeln bzw
verurteilung mit belegen und verwerfen
wir samt und sonders ganz und gar als
die vorausgeschickt wird je nach dem re
tisch oder anstößig oder falsch oder
froren verletzen oder einfache gemüte zu
führen und der katholischen wahrheit
widerstrebend also diese tiefe
hat der katholischen kirche und im tanz
überhaupt nicht gefallen das heißt
nutzer ab sich extrem und vermarktet und
damit ist er in konfrontation zwischen
auch im internet war natürlich auch da
unerhört persönlich zu werden
und das hat dann in der folge ein ganz
bekannt machen von den katalogen oder
auch teilweise philosophen zumindest
humanisten dazu veranlasst eine gegen
schrift zu verfassen
das erasmus von rotterdam wir kennen
alle erasmus stipendium das kennen wir
das muss von rotterdam und die hat eine
schrift verfasst mit dem titel die liebe
omi trio also vom freien willen und
genaugenommen luther gerichtet sind und
ich lese ich auch mal am tag vor der tat
muss hier in seiner schrift vom verein
will faktor
pelagius pilardio sich auch ein theologe
der spezialitäten vertrieben hatte dass
wir nicht die gnade der klage bedürfen
um so zu handeln dass sie frei sind im
guten wie im bösen handeln ohne signal
bisher lassen schreibt lage scheint den
freien willen mehr als nötig
zuzuschreiben weil wir eben ohne gottes
gnade gut und böse enden können
scholes coaches mitleidig auf und
schreibt ihm reiche nicht viel zu jetzt
kommt lothar verstümmelte ihm den willen
zunächst nur indem er ihm den rechten
arm abschnitt und dann nicht einmal
damit zufrieden brachte er den freien
willen um und beseitigte ihn völlig ich
billige die meinung jener die den freien
willen einiges zu schreiben aber der
gnade gottes
das meiste denn weder hätte man dieses
kühler der anpassung zu vermeiden müssen
dass man sich gegen die kult der
verzweiflung oder der sorglosigkeit
treiben ließ noch hätte man ein
verhängtes glied auf die weiße hai
dürfen dass man es in die
entgegengesetzte richtung verändern man
hätte es an seinen platz zurück bringen
müssen noch hätte man mit dem feind
vorne so kämpfen dürfen dass man aus
mangel an vorsicht gebeten verwundet
wurde
hier sieht man klar dass lassen muss wer
mit teenager hatte ja und durchaus mit
luthers lehre gibt nicht einverstanden
waren ja das kann man sagen er war ein
gegenpol zu luther oder worden da man
auf den funke hat er hat also ich meine
sie waren jetzt eigentlich der these
dass der menschliche wille alle können
aber sie waren doch letztendlich
hinsichtlich der frage nach der feier
zum guten und bösen mit gnade ohne gnade
so etwas reagieren und ich lese noch zum
schluss ein zitat von luther vor einer
weise vielleicht sehr klar seine tiefe
in beiden filmen verdeutlichte sagt wir
tun alles aus notwendigkeit nicht
ausfallen denn die kraft freien willens
vermögen ist nichts und tut nichts oder
mag nichts gutes wenn die gnade gottes
gnade können da kann etwas zur
menschlichen willen ein sehr
interessantes bild so ist der
menschliche wille in die mitte gestellt
wie ein stier und kurz darauf sitzt will
und geht es wohin gott will im saarland
darauf sitzt will und geht es wohin sagt
handeln und es liegt nicht an lange
währen zu mögen
zu einem von beiden reitern zu laufen
oder ihm suchen vielmehr streiten die
reiter selbst herum es mitzunehmen
unbedingt zu halten
das ein interessantes bild des
menschlichen gehen ja auf alle fälle
jörg vielen dank die aufklärung was
dieses jahres für die gute
zusammenfassung und die interessanten
zitate im so an unseren film cast fans
und zuschauer und interessierte ich
hoffe du gott noch lernen und wieder